[Musica]
cosa vuoi
tutto bello aiutare dottore ti prego
dopo che mai lasciato sull'altare ancora
che li cerchi noto non capire quanto
torre del problema tutt ora per un
bambino cosa no no non essere quello che
pensi totò riavere bambino ma essere il
frutto di e sta vedendo cosa stai
combinando totò rea del bambino ma verrà
il problema perché bambino non fare pipì
trita quindi più dovere spiegare al
dottore come insegnare al bambino fare
pipì guarda ci sono due persone che ho
aiutato io personalmente a fare la pipì
nel vasino perché è stato queste persone
se va bene ti aiuti auguri
buongiorno studenti è pervenuti a nuove
elezioni tipo torre col nuovo
esperimento di nuova stagione di
esperimenti credibile oggi aveva portato
amici dopo di che essere ton il bump
mantelle e jacopo fan punt helen
entrambi laureati all'università di
espresso oggi totore fare dimostrazione
incredibile tutti voi e anche a colleghi
attori perché totò che vogliono sapere
ma avere i poteri inservienti guardare
perché oggi dottore dare anche voi
dimostrazioni di potere magico totore fa
comparire nipote dovrà essere di botte
ma non è detto che dire
[Musica]
i bot e tito torres bambolotti che usano
io tra tre anni nel 1944 toghe a bere
suo nipote bellissimo che adorare un
sacco ma averla problema panchine e sa
che molto intelligente aver incorporato
chiavi in faccia anche baffi però non
sapere fare cosa fondamentale e non
parlare di esperimenti parlare di
svuotare de sica pil e perché no pp nenè
sarà il signore degli anelli
ciao pisciare di charles essere verbo
giusto nipote avere il problema di
urinare rovinare come si dice i primi
ricordi nostri beni di coordinate esatte
voi partecipato guerra coordinate sosta
ma meno ricordare
dov'era il calar le braghe ma il senso
così impasto infinito di totoro
posizione michael jackson ha con sé
pocket i pampini epp uscire direttamente
nei vasetti noi preme restare macchiando
più dottore respinge eliminare tutto
dove sarà finita youtube italia gli
ultimi sei anni e un po di brio blu e
non c'è a quel momento guardare come si
fa male un po incapace incapace to
sorella in perfetto torres sarei anche
fu rivista di scienza sa chi sono io
dottore essere rivista di scienza il mio
dimostrare poi che toccò ad essere sui
shock scimpanzé che vuoi trovare in
edicola miss ambiente italiano toghe
magazine grazie inservienti corriere non
è arrivato anche il dottore cialtrone
riviste ma totò rabbia che soluzione
dare guardare qua
89 non aver visto che voleva salvare
dottore dottore stava osservando
pacchetti di figurine perché oggi
dottore essere presente sul nuovo shop
scimpanzé planet hicks avesse alimenti
incredibile in copertina bellissimo e se
vuoi aprire tra le tic se trovare gli
esperimenti di settore dove era
assolutamente trovarlo in edicola e
prendere si è stabilmente perché totoro
insegnare noi cose nuove
dentro album trovare anche pacchetti di
figurine perché vuoi poter fare
collezioni di figurine e anche aiutare
capitan banana osservare gli animali non
è finita qui perché totò che oggi di
rajoy che potete partecipare a concorso
su pianeti hicks concorso spaziale con
tutta la vostra classe dottore avere
fatto vedere che essere veramente
superiore e avere anche trovato
soluzione per bambino per fare pipì
come fare par pp apam pino ninfa 7
prendere bambini va bene riempito questo
molto bravo che ne avrà in alto bambine
mettere pasini qua eto'o toghe scrutare
proprietà fisica di elettrostatici ti
anche su pc dove prendere pezza e
pregare sul palloncino si vuole venire
questo weekend propinare casa dittatori
va bene prendere ma se ti mettere qua
prendere panchine mentre in alto torre
dare da bere a fantino che ppe uscire
eletto staticità deviarla e ppt panchine
e finire il passetto il giorno il nord
far funzionare se ne andava fatto che
non vedere come puoi pensare che si
possa fare quello che in questa città e
il basettino guida il bambino che metti
il palloncino qui quindi rigetto caso ma
leva di la bomba di quali basi non ne
parla di quasi cercato il censimento
daniel bahr pantè le star sprecando
palloncino per creare elettrostatici pt
pata che deviare eccetto di purina di
bambino dentro
usare anche i capelli in un problema
adesso lei alzate bambino e dare acqua
bambino in modo tale da fare urinare e
acqua a finire in passato perché lei
avvicinare questo è creare effetto
elettrostatici pitt apt attenzione avere
avuto presentimento bravo
[Musica]
basettino un mezzo riempito esperimento
riuscito quando noi strofinare
palloncino a non cedere alcuni elettroni
superficie di esse elettroni avere
scavalca negativa e quindi caricare
negativamente palesino molecola di acqua
che noi conosciamo come h2o da come
essere strutturata e salire nel tempo la
vita
questo significare che agirà come
piccolo ma niente con po il negativo e
molo positivo quando noi avvicinare
superficie nel palloncino caricata
negativamente parte positiva di molecole
di acqua essere attratta e flusso
scorrere tenderà infine a muoversi in
versi di s
finalmente esperimento di totoro è
concluso nipote contento pisciato e
anche totò corriere dare parco totale
questo essere parco incredibile di
scimpanzè guardare chi esserci qua
esserci vuoi somigliare a te non
somiglia rete no somiglia rame si
fotografa anche figurine perché questo
mese su planet hicks esserci anche
figurine molto belle ciò avesse
veramente importante voi oggi aveva
capito questa lezione veramente
importantissimo noi studiare molto più
grave il dottore dubitare dove vuoi
passare anche da canale ti fan con tel
perché dare un po di incitamento questi
nuovi dottori poco esperti iscriversi a
canali di totò ove e noi ci diamo un
massimo di
[Musica]